foreign
[Music]
Modern Machinery is now the lifeblood of
Agriculture fueling innovations that are
setting new standards
join us as we explore the captivating
Universe of robust agricultural machines
in the freshest advancements in farming
technology
[Music]
this is something you won't want to miss
next we have the rod tetragram a machine
with the ability to spray a large grass
area up to 56 meters the elevated cabin
independent from the device allows the
operator to have a clear view of the
surroundings
moreover the machine features a vast
container enabling continuous operation
for many hours without refueling with a
full-time four-wheel drive system it
boosts efficiency and handles rugged
terrain conditions with ease
[Music]
no exploration of agricultural machinery
would be complete without the mighty
72sm tractors and tillers
on a sprawling Thousand Acre Farm DSM
Fab Lister Stands Tall
its robust engine durable traction wheel
system and the Innovative integration of
a tractor and a tiller turn it into a
model of modern agriculture
using these Marvels not only boosts
productivity but also significantly
reduces manual labor ushering in a new
era in farming
so stick around with Hyper TV for more
exciting Journeys into the realm of
technological Marvels
[Music]
in the aftermath of substantial events
cleaning up a large area can be labor
intensive
however our next machine equipped with
two large suction heads and a container
can handle various types of trash with
just a single operator
with this machine we're one step closer
to protecting our living environment
foreign
[Music]
to large Farms specializing in
harvesting vegetables like beets and
carrots
with eight small wheels it effortlessly
navigates various field terrains and
high crop densities equipped with
Advanced depth control technology it
ensures efficient on the go digging
coupled with a cleaning system it
maximizes productivity while minimizing
loss delivering market-ready produce
[Music]
also in Sweden the New Holland tl90
tractor tirelessly collects grass to
create hay bales catering to the needs
of livestock
the grass is cut into rows left to dry
and then collected by this machine
it transforms the grass into compact
molds and stores them in a rear
compartment
truly an innovation in agricultural
efficiency
foreign
the uot 3000 a land reclamation and A4
station pipe grooving machine equipped
with six preset operating modes
thanks to this Innovative machine land
reclamation and afforestation have
become more accessible and efficient
[Music]
strawberries one of the most loved
fruits globally entice Farmers to you
s strawberry farms during harvest season
the task of harvesting strawberries
involves manual labor where Farmers
carefully select the best berries for
export to supermarkets or processing a
canning plants
[Music]
as Autumn Graces us with its presence
brussels sprouts are ripe for the
Harvest
known for their nutritional value these
popular crops are harvested with utmost
Precision using Advanced machines
ensuring an efficient Harvest of these
tiny Delicacies
the John Deere 135de
boasting a 238 horsepower engine and
equipped with a four-row plow mechanism
optimizes time and efficiency during
peanut harvesting and seeding
[Music]
for all who find this captivating don't
forget to like And subscribe to our
channel to stay updated on the
mesmerizing world of machines
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the vibrant world of Advanced
Machinery where the John Deere
1270e processor Reigns Supreme in the
forestry industry
[Music]
fitted with Innovative design and
Technology this Marvel swiftly and
accurately drops cuts and splits wood
optimizing Harvest
[Music]
power and Agility allow for Effective
operation across varied challenging
terrains
Beyond its practical applications this
machine is also a crucial asset in
Environmental Conservation thanks to its
top tier performance and Energy
Efficiency
amidst the bustling feel being harvested
two names stand out for their power
performance and Cutting Edge technology
then 930 Gene 6 and chrome big X 630.
the FED 930 Gene 6 represents the latest
generation of tractors boasting advanced
technology and high efficiency on the
other hand the Chrome big X 630 is a
grass collector and Harvester cleverly
designed with the structure of a turtle
offering convenience and flexibility in
cutting and shredding
the combination of the fent 930 Gene 6
and the chromebig x630 has resulted in a
remarkable impact on overall performance
and harvest outcomes
[Music]
thank you
the New Holland 7030 a renowned
agricultural tractor by New Holland made
its debut in 2007. it boasts a 6.7 liter
turbocharged diesel engine delivering a
maximum of 155 horsepower the t7030 is
also equipped with a four-wheel drive
system
4WD for robust traction and stability
across diverse terrains
foreign this tractor is the AVR GE Force
a powerful plow developed by friends and
agricultural
this plow designed with eight tracks
enhances both power and work efficiency
during farming operations
[Music]
s Herb Farm Oxbow specialized machines
and two John Deere tractors combined to
form a powerful harvesting complex
efficiently collecting herbs from a 10
acre field including salt tolerant ones
even in bloom
boosting productivity for farmers
foreign
the x-16 Walnut Harvester is an advanced
machine equipped with automatic
technology simplifying the collection
and separation of walnuts
its efficient mechanisms and systems
ensure a smooth and uniform separation
of walnuts from the tree
[Music]
the MB track 1000 a classic farming
machine introduced by Mercedes-Benz in
the
1980s represents their renowned luxury
car brand
yeah although it's still in service the
MB track 1000 comes with a specialized
fertilizer spreading system exclusively
compatible with this Tractor Model
however Mercedes-Benz has since
discontinued agricultural vehicles to
focus solely on the automotive sector
[Music]
consider the modic 3000 hydros an
extraordinary efficient pumpkin
Harvester
foreign
feature is a hydraulic drive system
enabling precise individual movements
[Music]
its meticulous design stands Testament
to efficiency and energy conservation
symbolizing progress and professionalism
in farming
[Music]
experience the remarkable capabilities
of the Vandal flailmower Pro 680
relax
[Music]
its powerful engine and dual cutting
system make it perfect for various
terrains from roads and Fields to
forests
[Music]
with its adjustable height it
masterfully maintains clean areas which
AIDS in crop production and livestock
breeding
[Music]
[Applause]
it uses six cutting sets to split
eggshells and separate yolks from egg
whites
its ability to provide a full separation
guarantees food safety and hygiene
[Music]
the Armada
9970 a state-of-the-art peanut Harvester
equipped with a six row head showcases
revolutionary technologies that
skillfully Harvest and separate peanut
shells from the soil
thanks to its ingenious spiral blades
the loss is minimal during the process
[Music]
the Auto Care gavel Epsilon pal finger
is a versatile machine utilized for wood
harvesting
it functions as a truck with a crane
unit installed on the front enabling
Swift and effortless transport and
stacking of wood blocks
The Machine's flexibility allows for
efficient lifting and placement of large
wood blocks onto the truck reducing time
and effort in the wood harvesting and
transportation process
[Music]
next we turn our gaze towards the class
lexion 760 TT a superior combined
Harvester
foreign
cutting and cleaning system make it an
efficient waste reducing machine
plus the intelligent control system
allows for automatic accurate operation
bringing convenience and efficiency to
users with this machine harvesting is
not just a task but a rewarding
experience that yields Time Savings and
productivity gains for the agricultural
industry
the datron M8 Cube CNC machine a
high-end tool in the metal and plastic
processing industry pre-programs wheel
hubs and designs using CIA dcam software
for precision
[Music]
its advanced technology and high grade
spindle allow fast accurate Machining of
aluminum materials making it a symbol of
innovation and perfection
[Music]
thank you
previously mowing grass on hilly terrain
seemed like an unsolvable problem
however agricultural Engineers devised a
solution the Brio mayor motor Maher this
ingenious device can cut grass on
sloping terrain by optimizing weight and
using large spiked Wheels to ensure
traction and movement in rugged areas
thanks to this machine the complex
problem of mowing grass on steep hills
has been resolved making it a valuable
tool for the agriculture industry
[Music]
now fast forward to 2023 and welcome the
next app product line from Germany
featuring the most modern lawnmower
known to mankind
with a machine length of 30 meters in
spray arms that can stretch an
astonishing 56 meters taking care of
lush greenfields has never been more
accessible or spectacular
but beware operating this machine
requires expertise and experience
it's not just a device it's a statement
[Music]
next Imagine a busy roadside lined with
trees
how do we ensure safety without damaging
the environment enter the cenovich in
718e a versatile crane hailing from the
renowned construction and Industrial
Machinery Company cinemagen it's
designed to trim trees along busy
corridors ensuring traffic safety and
maintaining power lines what's more it's
equipped with an automatic control
system letting operators work remotely
and increasing overall safety
it's not just a tree cutting crane it's
a guardian of safety
wondered about the technology behind
dredging and sucking mud in riverbeds
here's a miracle machine exactly for
that
[Music]
share your guesses about its name in the
comments
[Music]
welcome to the world of Massey Ferguson
a prestigious name in The Realm Of
Agricultural machinery
its Legacy began with the Massey
Ferguson 35 a versatile utility tractor
that came to life in the 1960s
designed for resilience and performance
it swiftly became a farmer's trusted
companion for plowing and various other
farming tasks truly the Massey Ferguson
line of tractors embodies Decades of
innovation and commitment to the
agricultural industry
[Music]
plowing thousands of meters of Farmland
has never been easier thanks to rapidly
advancing technology
[Music]
to vent 942 trackers each equipped with
a kerneline 12 row plow create perfect
grooves a testament to the professional
performance of modern agricultural
machinery
[Music]
the Firefly automatics are 300 a master
of the soccer field
this automated roll Harvester swings
into action meticulously moving back and
forth harvesting rolls of grass with
ease
foreign
[Music]
as it Glides over each row an integrated
arm lifts and two cutting blades sliced
through the roots leaving behind a
perfectly clean surface
this automated gem adjusts The Cutting
depth as required removing the sod
without any disturbance
[Music]
in the United States millions of cars
that have reached their end of life are
scrapped each year
[Music]
to achieve this The Argus VZ 950 comes
into play a medium-sized Shredder that
crushes cars into small pieces like a
jaw Crusher
its large main shaft houses crushing
knives arranged in a v-shape firmly
attached and continuously rotating
anything not just cars that is this
machine will be crushed into small
pieces
foreign
[Music]
comes with an automatic potato
harvesting system ensuring high
efficiency at approximately one to two
hectares per hour
equipped with a conveyor belt it easily
pushes the potatoes into a 4.5 cubic
meters container allowing for more
potatoes to be harvested at once and
reducing unloading time
with a working width of 80 to 90
centimeters it is suitable for various
fields and terrains
[Music]
device is specifically designed for
harvesting agricultural products
particularly fruits and vegetables like
apples pears strawberries tomatoes
peppers and more
equipped with efficient components like
fan blades and rollers it minimizes
product damage during Harvest
the melon harvesting machine also offers
a high level of adjustability for the
fan blades enabling the harvesting of
various types of crops
[Music]
protection for your services look no
further than slat tracks this this Nifty
technology safeguards everything from
grass and artificial turf
to soil and wetlands from the wear and
tear of heavy machinery
[Music]
with easy attachment to machines like
Bobcats or skid steers it's a practical
solution to an everyday problem
[Music]
thank you
let's introduce you to the vht Shaker an
Innovative harvesting Marvel
this intelligent machine Embraces Tree
Trunks and shakes them causing fruits to
rain down in record time
the adjustable vibration intensity and
speed allow users to tailor its
operation for various crops a
personalized approach to harvesting
[Music]
next in line is the dudesfar m3575
combined Harvester a mid-range leader in
its class
manufactured by juice far and equipped
with Advanced tools and Cutting Edge
features this combined Harvester isn't
just a productivity tool
it's a symbol of Pride and efficiency
that brings emotion to the hard work of
harvesting
[Music]
now
TI Harvester a groundbreaking addition
to the oil palm cultivation industry
known for its capacity to separate
leaves and stems in a single harvesting
process its modern design which includes
a spacious cabin and Innovative features
ensures a comfortable operating
experience
thank you
further enhancing productivity and
efficiency the Harvester comes equipped
with technology allowing it to adapt to
varying Field Heights and terrains
[Music]
a motion simulation device that's not
just for entertainment it's for training
too
picture yourself driving flying or even
climbing a mountain SIM can replicate
those movements with high precision
[Music]
foreign
with realistic Sensations and a
beautifully created virtual world Sim
offers an escape into thrilling and
authentic experiences interested in
owning one stay tuned
[Music]
let's turn our gaze now to Poland where
Farmers Ingenuity has given birth to a
one-of-a-kind creation
he's designed a robot breathing new life
into the engine of a small discarded car
capable of a staggering 248 horsepower
thanks to the farmer's Keen intellect
and Innovative Spirit we're witnessing
farming in the age of robots
[Music]
on the scene is the nipro scr-302j a
Marvel in agriculture and Horticulture
it's not just a piece of Machinery it's
a game changer
attach it to a large tractor and it
swiftly creates efficient folds dividing
Fields like never before it's farming
made effortless and it's here to
redefine how we work the land
[Music]
welcome to Sweden a leading industrial
nation home to the DeWolf GBC carrot
Harvester operated in conjunction with
the John Deere 5820 tractor
[Music]
with delicate Precision it harvests
carrots placing them on a screening
conveyor to separate soil leaves and
roots
the roots are then collected and
transported on a conveyor belt to a
storage bin
imagine the Simplicity such technology
brings to the entire process
[Music]
meet the Clay's Jaguar 990 TT an
exceptional Harvester of grass and other
crops
driven by a 24 liter Ma and V12 diesel
engine it boasts a horsepower of up to
925.
[Music]
harvesting vast fields of corn grass and
other crops becomes a walk in the park
with this machine which can handle
hundreds of tons of hay per hour
foreign
as the Morning Mist lingers witnessed
the Kubota M72 tractor preparing the
soil for the next season's crop
[Music]
armed with a six-cylinder diesel engine
6.1 liter displacement and a mighty 170
horsepower it's a force to reckon with
the tractor's plow blades and integrated
soil pole verizers enable Swift tilling
in just one pass
foreign
next we Spotlight the Brar KES Max 6000
TS an automatic slabber that redefines
grass cutting
[Music]
it's a Marvel that dissects grass into
smaller pieces tailored to the user's
preference
[Music]
the conveyor system assists in reshaping
the grass into desired sizes while the
cooling system ensures the blade
sharpness and efficiency promising fast
and precise cutting
[Music]
thank you
say hello to the Ant-Man pcha specialist
in sausage making
this machine can create and package
various types of sausages with
adjustable sizes and weights ensuring a
tight clamp to prevent breakage or
separation during transportation
finally the packages are hung ready for
preservation and transport
[Music]
meet the Amazon
edx6000t see an automatic sea drill and
fertilizer spreader that left me in awe
of technological progression
[Music]
with Precision operations enhancing
agricultural efficiency this machine can
cooperate with a range of tractors
including new Holland's ta-360t
7270 Auto command and TG 285
foreign by automating the seating and
fertilizing process it promotes cost
Effectiveness in agriculture
[Music]
picture of vast field carpeted with ripe
red tomatoes a quintessential summer
scene
[Music]
in comes a harvesting machine navigating
through the dense rows of tomatoes
picking each one individually
[Music]
after hours of operation it leaves
behind containers brimming with Splendid
red tomatoes this year's record-breaking
16-ton Harvest a testament to a fruitful
season and optimal weather conditions
foreign
[Music]
imagine a small garden where men
commands the mighty Bandit sg40 machine
with finesse and precision
[Music]
this Garden Keeper's right hand tool
effortlessly processes tree stumps
leaving no room for the unnecessary dead
or damaged
[Music]
this compact yet robust stump grinder
saves him time and energy turning a
tough task into a breeze
[Music]
now we introduce the Union Spring spring
winding machine a Marvel of automation
this machine spends a web of precision
and ease making it simpler than ever to
produce a variety of spring products on
Mass
from Cars to electronics these Springs
find their homes in countless
applications proving that even the
smallest components can be a testament
to human ingenuity
Feast your eyes on the tractor of
tractors the 1100 GP born in Germany
it's a testament to Advanced Technology
and versatile agricultural practices
[Music]
it has the power to till so and harvest
making farming a seamless task
[Music]
witnessing this Titan plant corn across
the breathtaking Landscapes of Saxony
and halt truly underscores the booming
large-scale industrial growth in Germany
next behold the maxillator accumide
grapple
[Music]
mounted on a towing vehicle the
sufficient grapple attachment takes the
burden of transporting hay bales from
the truck to the storage site
yeah
the gripping arm controlled by a piston
and valve ensures a firm hole on the hay
optimizing movement and significantly
reducing operation time
[Music]
listen that's the deep growl of the eat
of balance round massage machine hard at
work its large Wheels crunching over
rocks and stones while its Mighty engine
lines with intensity
as it prowls the field it doesn't just
pick up rocks it processes them sorting
and filtering them with Precision from
soil and other elements
a built-in sieve infiltration system
eliminates some wanted stones and debris
such as grass or waste efficiently
sifting the necessary from the
unnecessary
the purified stones are then transported
to the machine storage compartment ready
for removal it's not just a machine it's
a Titan of the field
[Music]
foreign moving to Poland we introduced
the ursus
1614 Deluxe lawnmower a luxury grass
harvesting equipment
[Music]
paired with the tarup 605 grass
Harvester these machines efficiently cut
grind and harvest grass for fodder
[Music]
both are products of tar-up a leading
polish manufacturer specializing in
harvesting and forage processing
equipment
[Music]
thank you
next consider a Monumental achievement
in Russia
where a pesticide sprayer has been
invented that can cover thousands of
square meters of sunflowers in just
three hours
by flying in a zigzag pattern this
programmed aircraft ensures that no spot
is left untreated
[Music]
meet the Harry pilot autonomous robot a
Marvel designed for precision farming
this device employs Advanced drilling
technology to plant crops at exact
locations autonomously by replacing
manual labor it enhances efficiency and
saves considerable time
[Music]
on the equestrian front the Curt system
is revolutionizing horse training
it can guide young horses through an
intense regimen at speeds up to 30 miles
per hour on a one mile circular track
and it doesn't just train it monitors
assessing heart rate respiratory rate
even bone and muscle development that's
technology working in harmony with
nature
[Music]
the br200 is a handheld gasoline-powered
leaf blower with a two-stroke engine
weighing around 5.7 kilograms it
features an anti-vibration system for
reduced shaking during use
with an airspeed of up to 241 kilometers
per hour and an airflow rate of 730 M3
per hour it easily blows away light
debris like leaves grass and dirt from
finished areas
[Music]
now as we journey to India a country of
nearly 1.4 billion people experiencing
rapid Economic Development we observe a
soaring demand for bricks
[Music]
this has given rise to the bmm 300 an
exceptional machine capable of producing
millions of bricks daily
[Applause]
[Music]
it's equipped with mold carrying wheels
that streamline the brick making process
by keeping the bricks in the location of
production eliminating the need for
additional relocation
foreign
[Music]
clearing large stumps used to be a
back-breaking task but not anymore
[Music]
special machines armed with strong fast
rotating sawtee transform these stumps
into sawdust making cleanup or Breeze
[Music]
[Applause]
agricultural Machinery like the chantier
alcxl is designed to work continuously
and efficiently across large fields
its powerful engines and large plow
blades dig deep into the ground
[Music]
preparing the soil for sowing weed seeds
and creating an ideal well-aerated
environment
[Music]
hailing from the land of engineering
Marvels Germany the next at Harvest
Germany MIT 15.5 M and 1100 PS combined
Harvesters Sands is a giant in the world
of Miranda steinderell Harvest spiral
Harvest Style
with its impressive 20 meter width and a
motor capacity of 1100 PS This colossal
machine can even be controlled remotely
if you're a farmer or Rancher looking to
Skyrocket your productivity and slash
Harvest Time this could be the machine
of your dreams
let's take a step back in time to
September 2019 where we witnessed a Ford
6000 Commander tractor a
1960s classic equipped with a rock
filter mechanism
this formidable combination undertook
the challenging task of sieving soil and
removing rocks from a vast 112 hectare
field
[Music]
in the U.S large-scale plows are vital
cogs in the wheel of modern agriculture
armed with 12 plows these machines can
cover a breadth of up to 3.5 meters
transforming sprawling Fields into
fertile ground in just hours
[Music]
by Saving Time and Labor they help
reduce production costs and boost crop
yield
[Music]
modern CNC machines known for their
intricate turning and cutting designs
are indispensable in the production of
small to large parts
[Music]
with perfect Precision powered by
Advanced computer technology
[Music]
machines have brought significant
benefits to the mechanical industry
[Music]
once creating murals required skillful
hands
today engineered machines have risen to
the task
upon receiving image data these machines
craft programs that guide them along the
i-axis moving left to right and spraying
precise colors to recreate the image the
[Music]
the result is a stunning mural bearing
an astonishing 99 similarity to the
original image
[Music]
meet the Power arm 3430 a hedge trimmer
that's more than just a cutter
with its compact design and adjustable
rotating blade that moves up to 270
degrees it can adapt to any cutting
position
and it doesn't stop there with a cutting
width of up to one meter and razor sharp
blades it effortlessly trims Hedges and
other vegetation
the real magic lies in its direct
suction feature collecting the cup Parts
into a container saving precious time
and effort in cleaning up
it's not just trimming it's
revolutionizing the way we care for our
landscapes
[Music]
moving on to the realm of Forestry and
fruit tree cultivation we find another
specialist in machine deftly tailored to
Chestnut harvesting
a symphony of Parts a harvesting head
conveyor belt and processing system work
in Perfect Harmony
[Music]
the harvesting head rotating and
hovering just above the ground Scoops up
chestnuts with surgical precision
notably it can be adjusted to suit
different tree types
then a sophisticated filtration system
purges impurities leaving behind only
the finest most pristine chestnuts
[Music]
imagine the complexities of harvesting
tomatoes the delicate nature of the
fruit and the plant itself poses a
daunting challenge doesn't it
[Music]
but behold through the magic of
engineering a miracle machine has
emerged with delicate Precision it
separates tomatoes and transports them
onto a conveyor belt before moving them
into the storage compartment of a
waiting tractor truck
[Applause]
we now cross over to a field in the
Netherlands where the Grim rexor 930 a
self-propelled beet Harvester is hard at
work
crafted by Grimm a specialist in
agricultural equipment the ricksor 930
is capable of harvesting nine rows at
once enhancing yield and harvest
efficiency
Additionally the re-4000 a heavy duty B
transporter Works in perfect sync with
the grimrixor 930 transporting a sizable
load of sugar beets from the Harvester
the Synergy between the grimrixor 930
and are you 4000 paints a picture of
agricultural efficiency saving labor
while maximizing output
[Music]
now let's uncover the magic behind onion
harvesting with the hellerous union
loofmeyer union Royer 225 front Combi
this tool attached to the front of a
machine uses a blade to pick up onions
from the ground significantly increasing
the speed and efficiency of onion
harvesting
[Music]
Cherry Farmers rejoice
the intelligent shaking machine is here
to make harvesting faster and more
efficient
[Music]
it hugs the tree trunk shakes the
cherries firmly into a box and they fall
right onto a conveyor simple time saving
and highly effective of brilliant
addition to Modern farming
foreign
[Music]
Hill another Titan takes the spotlight
this monstrous tractor and I say
monstrous for a reason digs planting
holes with raw power
look at those four wheels all Chained
and driven by forceful engines
are you seeing this
it's the brute strength of Agriculture
unveiled
for to the score
serve designed with four fan blades this
impressive device can Ascend to a height
of 10 meters and reach speeds up to 50
kilometers per hour
however flight time is limited to
approximately 20 minutes before
requiring a recharge piloting the
Scorpion 3 either manually or via a
smartphone app through Bluetooth is a
challenge that calls for experienced
hands for ensuring safety
[Music]
if you find our content intriguing we
encourage you to hit the like button and
subscribe to our Channel
this way you'll never miss our
insightful videos on this topic
meet the case
9370 tractor a beast of a machine
engineered explicitly for the
agricultural industry its sheer power is
a sight to be whole and it's only one of
the incredible tools revolutionizing
farming today
open to Mr seblon's hamburger pastry
shop where the sponge cake machine works
its magic
[Music]
with just flour and spices as inputs
this machine expertly mixes the
ingredients and pumps them into preset
molds
the result is a delicious cake flipped
at the perfect moment which many
customers claim to be better than
homemade
[Music]
our journey continues in The Verdant
fields of spinach where the automatic
new herbex 9200 range Supreme
Farmers trust this machine for its a
match capability to harvest up to six
rows of Greens in one go
it's sharp blades coupled with a
vibrating mechanism ensures seamless
precise cut every time
but it doesn't stop there this machine
is a complete package offering a
built-in truck to contain and package
the harvested greens
[Music]
now if you've ever dreamed of stepping
into the shoes of a modern tech savvy
farmer you've come to the right place
hyper tv offers you a chance to
experience the diverse agricultural
Landscapes across the globe
so hit that subscribe button and stay
tuned
step into Mr seblon's hamburger pastry
shop where the sponge cake machine works
its magic
with just flour and spices as inputs
this machine expertly mixes the
ingredients and pumps them into preset
molds
the result is a delicious cake flipped
at the perfect moment which many
customers claim to be better than
homemade
[Music]
ever wondered where your wine originates
picture a clear morning in Australia's
Griffith region where diligent Farmers
operate the mystery grape Harvester
machines
serving some of the largest wineries in
the southern hemisphere these machines
underscore the rich wine-making
tradition of the region
picture Serene Ranch
kennel Grays but what's that strange
machine
it's a specially designed cattle rake a
testament to the love and care given to
our livestock
this machine does more than just look
quirky it suits the itching of our
animals gently scratching their hides to
provide relief from pesky insects
now let's enter the future with the home
robot hero bot
[Music]
attached to the buser rotary hole
Plantation cultivator this automatic
tiller is like a farmer's best friend
ordinary turning agriculture it's not
just tilling digging or preparing the
soil for sowing it's doing it with the
intelligence and efficiency of modern
robotics
[Music]
thank you
we turn our attention to an industrial
Marvel the hacker machine
this Powerhouse transforms large pieces
of wood into manageable chips with
astonishing efficiency
Guided by a specialized crane Timber
Finds Its way into this machine only to
emerge as finely ground pieces ready for
use in transport
the contained been awaiting these chips
Tells A Tale of power and efficiency
[Music]
a truck equipped with a revolutionary
turbelia uclaim mechanism
[Music]
its large container makes harvesting
agricultural products like hey essench
[Music]
as the conveyor belt swiftly lifts and
stacks the products the machine
meticulously arranges them into a
particular shape and layout
[Music]
Witnesses this mechanical Wonder
transforms hay harvesting into a
fascinating inefficient valet of
machinery
foreign
[Music]
ing through a vast peanut field
effortlessly harvesting and filtering
peanuts with the sheer technological
Marvel of the peanut Harvester
hailing from one of the leading
countries in the world this machine
doesn't just make harvesting peanuts
easy it makes it an art
[Music]
the buggy it equipped with a specialized
box stores the processed peanuts while
the nozzle acting as an optimally
designed conveyor belt funnels them into
the vehicle's storage compartment
thank you
but what about maintaining a sprawling
grass field of nearly a thousand
hectares
Sugar Land near its fertilizer spreader
born in Germany and crafted with
Precision this heavy equipment Sports
two arms in an extension nozzle reaching
up to 30 meters
[Music]
capable of holding 50 cubic meters of
fertilizer this uniquely designed
Masterpiece is not just about increasing
productivity it's about saving time and
honoring craftsmanship
[Music]
our journey continues with trop18 a
formidable truck that's much more than
just a vehicle
designed specifically for testing
construction mining Drilling and
scientific research Tron 20 is a
testament to resilient engineering
with its sturdy frame large wheels and
flexible suspension system this vehicle
conquers the toughest terrains Hills
deserts dense forests even bodies of
water with ease
but the real jewel in the crown is the
T3 drilling rig a compact versatile tool
capable of geotechnical drilling
environmental drilling and mineral
extraction tasks
with a trump windy no terrain is too
challenging no task too daunting
[Music]
now observe the workings of an
ingeniously designed automatic textile
machine
relying on the simple up and down
movement of a hook and rotational action
around a shaft this machine transforms
each thread plate into fabric a
testament to a programmer's Ingenuity
this mechanism has become indispensable
in textile factories
picture an Australian weed field during
harvest season two mechanical Titans New
Holland tx-66 and Case IH
7120 combine Harvesters work side by
side reaping wheat with astounding
efficiency the TX 66 boasts a
turbocharged diesel engine an electronic
fuel injection in contrast the IH 7120 a
product of case Corporation subsidiary
of c h industrial is purpose-built for
efficient harvesting from wheat to Corn
soybean to Canola they are harvesting
powerhouses
[Music]
thank you
in modern livestock and poultry Farms an
automated waste removal system is
commonplace
[Music]
this ingenious system eases the task of
waste collection pushing manure into
designated areas through simple conduits
or pushers
programmable for automatic operation
this system not only minimizes
time-consuming cleanup tasks but also
boosts production efficiency
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
construction akin to Art begins with
graders and excavators preparing the
ground
following that a hot asphalt delivery
truck spreads asphalt onto the prepared
surface
next a stone spreader machine smoothens
the layer and ensures its firm adherence
giving birth to an attractive durable
Road
[Music]
thank you
ever laid your eyes on a professional
agricultural Marvel like the qns Pro
6000 ER
RoR effortlessly plows and sow seeds for
turnips across a vast 500 hectare field
marking the star art of a new growth
cycle
pressed wood products have found their
way into our daily lives thanks to their
beautiful designs and cost effectiveness
[Music]
witness the beauty of a modern planned
wood production line debarking planning
stacking pressing every step leading to
Precision engineered wood blocks
[Music]
they're then sanded and cut to desired
dimensions for the ultimate finish
[Music]
meet the verado BET 70 283 a sturdy
machine designed to spread fertilizer
across vast grasslands
[Music]
capable of holding up to 32 000 tons of
fertilizer and with a six wheel load
capacity it extracts liquid fertilizer
and distributes it following a preset
pattern
foreign
thanks to its large wheels and
suspension mechanism it easily navigates
rough terrains minimizing operator
fatigue
the Lush grasslands of the Netherlands
play host to dairy farms in need of
ample fodder enter the first generation
fan favorite 916 vario a tractor with a
formidable resume this power horse
introduced in 1996 is a specialist at
Towing fodder trailers with its
revolutionary transmission it can
conquer any terrain and single-handedly
pick up grass truly a Marvel to behold
[Music]
witness the wheat harvest season in the
expansive fields of Germany
the search for a machine capable of
efficiently completing this task ends
with the class lexian Harvester
[Music]
from the first glance is impossible to
fully articulate the power and advanced
technology it houses no wonder it's sold
and used worldwide
[Music]
the John Deere s 685i is a giant combine
harvester produced by John Deere
[Music]
it is designed to harvest and thresh
various crops including wheat with a
wide operating width of 14 meters with
this machine's quick and efficient
capabilities it can process large
amounts of produce
the dust blower system featuring
multiple fans throughout the machine
effectively removes dirt and sand during
Harvest ensuring Optimal Performance and
minimizing adverse impacts while in
operation
[Music]
next meet the waratah 622b a leading
logging machine hailing from Northern
Ontario Canada
[Music]
its precision and reliability meet the
demands of the complex Forest
environment
foreign
[Music]
it's this ability to quickly and
accurately cut and split wood that's
made the war toss 622b a stalwart in the
industry aiding in efficient and
sustainable logging operations
if you have a passion for agriculture
subscribe to our channel for updates and
the opportunity to learn from experts in
the field
together let's build a sustainable
agricultural community
thank you the task of spreading compost
on grasslands has advanced significantly
with the green cargo machine this
vehicle combines three modern mechanisms
a scoop and front Hopper a crushing and
rotating system and a spreading
mechanism for even distribution
[Music]
[Applause]
with this Advanced Machinery and
Technology spreading organic fertilizers
or other nutrients on grasslands has
become faster and more efficient than
ever before now observe the mighty fent
828 a robust tractor paired with the
Grim eight row potato planner
the duo ensures Swift accurate potato
planning optimizing efficiency saving
time and ensuring an abundant potato
supply for local and international
markets
their teamwork epitomizes productivity
saving labor and time of professional
solution from VD born
thank you
introducing the Merlot multi-farmer 44.9
CS 170 a versatile machine that
functions as both a tractor and a
backhoe
with 170 GP and the latest remote
control system seavertronic performance
additionally this multi-farmer is
equipped with the class liner 2900 grass
rake which efficiently collects grass
and vegetation during harvesting and
feed processing
[Music]
the Kubota SL 600 A specialized machine
excels in beautifying field fences and
creating effective borders
foreign
[Music]
six engine and 8-speed gearbox provide
unrivaled Power with multi-functional
features ensuring stable operation even
on challenging terrains
[Music]
the 620 packaging line one of the most
advanced Solutions in food production
caters to the growing Global demand for
sausages
[Music]
its intelligent design enables the Swift
and impressive production of a variety
of foods including sausages meat paint
and salads
[Music]
thank you this amazing tractor can plow
over 800 hectares of land per day thanks
to modern tools
[Music]
it significantly improves tillage
productivity for farmers do you know its
name and unique structure
foreign
Marvel at the Oxbow
2475 in action harvesting corn in Lush
fields
[Music]
its series cutting blades release
kernels leaving behind a mesmerizing
sight of a cornfield gradually
disappearing and the container slowly
filling up with the Bounty of the
Harvest
[Music]
the espanda park is a distinct fruit
Harvester specially designed for crops
like grapes walnuts and dates
it uses shaking clamps to gently
dislodge and collect the fruit from
trees of different heights and widths
[Music]
the catching structure covers the widest
canopy portion leaving no fruit behind
this sufficient device saves time and
ensures safety compared to manual
harvesting methods
foreign
XXL quad track Case IH 535 tiller is a
Marvel of modern agricultural Machinery
technology
[Music]
with Cutting Edge features and
exceptional adaptability this tiller
stands out in the agricultural industry
it serves as both a working tool and a
symbol of progress and enjoyment in
agriculture making it a remarkable
choice for Farmers seeking Innovation
and efficiency
[Music]
the library at R 984 C excavator boasts
a robust Engine with up to 1140
horsepower capable of lifting payloads
of up to 14 tons
[Music]
due to its immense power it is commonly
employed in large mining operations the
excavator features a spacious
comfortable and safe cabin equipped with
an air conditioning system adjustable
seating and various devices that Aid the
operator in controlling the machine
comfortably and safely
foreign
[Music]
tiger is a colossal radish Harvester
manufactured by ropa farzo and mashin in
Bao GM Bay a germany-based company
this giant beast in the field of
Agriculture boasts an impressive size
and extraordinary strength
[Music]
moreover the ropa tiger is equipped with
Advanced Technologies including an
automatic control system soil and debris
removal system and a sugar beet
screening and conveying system
[Music]
the fence 724 vario tractor manufactured
by the well-known company fent in the
agricultural Machinery industry is a
powerful agricultural tractor
[Music]
it comes equipped with an advanced
Brewer toward automatic fertilizer
system and a towing crane designed for
spreading fertilizer over grasslands
[Music]
this combination of the fence 724 vario
tractor the pasture traction lever and
the Brewer torch system ensures highly
efficient and precise agricultural
operations on the plains
foreign
Italy's renowned tomato Hub one
encounters efficient modern tomato
Harvesters that are reshaping the
harvesting process
by reducing labor and enhancing
productivity they ensure the harvested
Tomatoes retain their quality and
freshness contributing to traditional
Italian recipes and Global exports
now on to our unsung hero of
agricultural Innovation the a rock
picker machine
[Music]
this fantastic device is designed to
clean the Farmland of all those pesky
rocks stones and debris that pose a
threat to our crops
[Music]
with adjustable depth and pressure it
traverses the field collecting these
unwanted visitors from different depths
and Heights
with the land cleared Farmers enjoy an
improved soil quality which translates
to increased production efficiency and
crop yields
[Music]
thank you for embarking on this
fascinating Adventure Into The Cutting
Edge of farming Tech with us
[Music]
we've delved Into the Heart of modern
agriculture from the power pack machines
to advance farming methods
[Music]
dive Peak your interest ensure you like
subscribe and ring that Bell catch you
in our next video
till then keep farming and thriving